this question looks like it's going to
be hot up but in fact it's easier all
right so let's give this a go because
squared/x your remember and what this
really means this is just shorthand for
this okay that's what it really means
it's just kind of like less brackets
same meaning let's just write it like
this okay it's the whole thing that's
being squared
not just that little term next there
which is what it might look like if you
just wrote cos x squared so I do I
actually read then it's cos squared X
now being that that's what it means on
the left hand side we want to solve it
in terms of a true equation right so I'm
going to need to get rid of that squared
so we'll take the square root of both
sides but when you have a square take
the screen both sides what happens to
the right hand side you get a
fossilization okay
the square root of one is just one and
the square root of two is root 2 okay so
there you go
now this looks like it's worse but it's
actually much better because in all of
these examples we've just looked at you
have to pay attention to the sign and
you have to work at 1 Cayne wherever
about semi which values am i interested
in but now you're just interested in all
of them okay so rather than looking at
just two quadrants where you see a plus
minus you automatically know I'm going
to get an answer out of all four
quadrants okay what's the related angle
what's the basic angle you're gonna get
out of this yeah me too it's 45 minute
right coz 45 is 102 okay
so therefore excuse me I can go straight
to writing my for answers knowing that I
have to look at 45 in the first quadrant
second quadrant and third quadrant and
fourth quadrant okay just to make it
really instructive for you I'm gonna put
an extra step in but you don't have to
put in but it helps to think about this
the way you get the four answers in
cases not quit yet is you go from zero
forward and you go from 180 backwards
180
forwards and 360 backwards that's what
gives you your for actual angles okay so
your angles are gonna be 45 135 225
3:15 yeah comes up yes yes and I'll give
you any exact value so what you'll know
exactly if it's not any tech values what
you're asking and the answer is yes you
do son that's fine that's fine
um okay now we're starting to add layers
of complexity here okay so let's have a
go at this sine 2x equals our heart
rates up
now you may remember you may remember
from Lawson ah and your exercise when
you did the graph you on this but what
effect does is to have on our sine
function that's right step up what is
right so we're ready
sine 2x one way is to say it gets deeper
a point more accurate way to say it
because their trig functions and the
periodic is that it makes it more
frequent in fact it makes it twice as
big and if I put in 3x there it'll be 3
tons of free one and so on ok so again
you see could be paying you what about
this I think your best way to approach
this is by graphing the thing right
graph the thing here's what I'm gonna do
what does this um what is this look like
from 0 to 360 instead of having one copy
of the graph I'm just gonna have to
write it's gonna happen twice one two
done okay so now when I draw this line
through y equals 1/2
they have surprise surprise you have not
two but four solutions one two three
four okay so I'm gonna go about this the
way that I would have done it before
except there's just a slight differences
to X okay you may like to think about it
as being that X is between 0 and 360
right it's kind of as though 2x remember
we're doing inequalities before you got
to inequalities is really here we've got
X is greater than 0 and X is less than
360 but we treat them all as one thing
because we can do it all in one piece if
I have multiplied this by 2 right then
to have the safety on both sides I have
to multiply everything by 2 right 2
times 0 is still 0 but this will be 720
okay does that make sense so now when I
start to write out my solutions to X is
going to be equal to 4 sine x equals 1/2
what's up a single tell me single it's
30 degrees right so 30 degrees and then
my next one will be a hundred and fifty
and that's where usually where I would
stop because between 1 and 360 that's
all the solutions you've got yeah but
because I'm between of course I'm a 2x
there right I can you actually go
further right so what would my next
solution after husband 50
it'll be this plus 360 and then it'll be
this also plus 360 right which is five
ten nice they go that's 2x equals right
except I just want the answers for X not
answers for 2x
okay so I divide everything through by 2
which gives me 1575 195 and 255 which
were the four solutions that you can
even see that kind of makes sense look
at everything is kind of compressed
right 1575 195 255 Ness 360 roughly
where you would expect it